A local model on a 6-year-old graphics
card can now write your code all day for
free with you barely touching any paid
subscriptions. Nobody that rate limits
you, bumps the price, or quietly nerfs
the model you're working with. Sounds
like the move to make right now with
frontier models being rug pulled
overnight. Until you look at the current
prices of GPU and memory. It's ironic
that frontier capability is so close
within our reach, yet so far away. The
models crossed the line this year, but
the hardware to run them properly did
the opposite of getting cheaper. By the
end of this video, you'll know where
that line is, what it cost you to cross
it, and whether you're one of the people
who actually [music] should.
Running a model on your own machine used
to be a thing for hobbyists and [music]
the privacy obsessed. That changed in
June. A government order went out and
within [music] hours two of the most
capable models on the planet were
switched off for every customer in the
world without any prior notice.
>> [music]
>> You could be mid-project, paid up in
full, and the tool you'd built your week
around was just gone for reasons that
had nothing to do with you. That sits on
top of the stuff you already live with.
Models get retired on someone else's
schedule. Prices move. The version you
trusted gets replaced by one that
behaves differently. It sounds like a
landlord that changes the locks whenever
they feel like it, which is why people
started eyeing the box already sitting
under their desk. The real-life local
model metric. Do you still feel the need
to double-check its work against [music]
the cloud model? For a lot of developers
this year, the answer flipped to no.
What flipped it wasn't raw intelligence,
but tool calling. A coding agent is only
worth anything if it reliably reads your
files, runs your tests, and edits the
right lines. Older, small models faked
it. They'd happily describe code they'd
never opened.
>> [music]
>> Somewhere around the 27 to 35 billion
parameter mark, that got dependable. And
a model on your desk could finally
behave like an agent instead of a
chatbot. But, good enough carries an
asterisk. Local holds its own on bounded
work. Auto complete, quick code
questions, refactoring a module, writing
tests, well-specified [music] edits.
Hand it a big big multi-file job and let
it drive itself, and it still [music]
loses to the frontier, badly. One
developer put the trade nicely. A strong
local model is a sharp junior who knows
a little of everything, but needs
steering. Where the frontier is the
senior who thinks through the
architecture with you. [music]
If the senior gets you a 15x speed up,
the junior gets you five. For something
running free on hardware you already
own, that's still a little absurd. Now,
the catch. Crossing this line isn't just
a download away. It's a hardware
purchase, and one number decides nearly
everything. Memory. The model has to fit
in full in fast memory the GPU can
reach, or it crawls. The math is
friendly enough to do in your head. At
the compression people run in practice,
budget about half a gigabyte of memory
per billion parameters. A 32 billion
model then wants roughly 20 gigabytes
just to sit there before it reads a line
of your code. That's why 24 gigabytes of
VRAM is the number you keep hearing.
Below that, it's blunt. 16 gigabytes is
fine for auto complete and chat, not
much more. The floor where local starts
replacing the cloud for real work is a
24 gig graphics card, or a Mac with 32
to 48 gigs of unified memory. Watch for
one trap. Those fast mixture of experts
models only fire a few billion
parameters per word. So, people assume
they're light. They're not. The whole
model still has to live in memory at
once, and your context window rents
space from the same pool. [music] A long
one can eat 10 gigs by itself.
There's a quality dial, too.
Quantization, which is just how hard to
compress the weights. [music]
Push it too far and a coding model
starts failing where you can see it.
[music]
Broken tool calls, malformed JSON,
switching language halfway through a
[music] function. So, the rule is to run
a smaller model at high quality over a
big one crushed to fit. A sharp 27B
beats a lobotomized 70B every time. The
old comfort that hardware just gets
cheaper if you wait is running
backwards, though. The AI buildout has
sent memory prices through the roof.
Used 24 gig cards are appreciating like
wine. Capability landed on consumer
hardware right as consumer hardware got
expensive. Close enough to touch, priced
just out of reach. Say the hardware
sorted. Going from nothing installed to
a model writing code in your editor is
three pieces.
>> [music]
>> First, the engine. This is the program
that loads the model file and runs it.
The thing doing the math behind every
word it writes. On its own, it's a brain
in a jar. It can think and talk, but it
can't touch anything on your machine.
Llama.cpp is the common one. MLX if
you're on a Mac, and Ollama or LM Studio
are friendlier wrappers around the same
job. They all do the same. Run a small
server on your own computer, so
everything else can reach the model
through a local address. Usually
something like localhost port 11434.
Second, the harness. Most people have
never heard of this one, and it's what
separates a chatbot from an agent. The
harness gives the brain a body. When the
model writes open this file or run the
[music] tests, the harness is the
program that goes and does it. Pulls the
file off your disk, runs the command,
then feeds the result [music] back so
the model can decide its next move.
Without a harness, the model can only
describe what it would do. With one, it
edits your code, runs it, sees what
broke, and tries again.
By, aider, open code, client, those are
harnesses. Some live in your terminal,
some drop straight into your editor.
Third, pointing your editor at the
thing. Every cloud coding tool you've
ever used already talks to a model over
a web address with an API key. [music]
A local setup uses the identical wiring,
you just change the address. In your
editor's AI, you point it at that
localhost address from the first step.
Same plug, different socket. Except now
the model answering you sits on your
desk instead of in a data center.
>> [music]
>> The one command on ramps, Ollama, and LM
Studio get you running in 5 minutes and
hide all of this underneath. That
convenience has a price, according to
the local LLM community. They can hand
you a smaller model than you thought you
picked, or leave a lot of speed on the
floor. It's still fine to start easy to
prove the thing works at all, then
graduate to the manual tools when the
convenience start hiding something you
need to see.
One last warning that saves a brutal
first day. Don't take the big name cloud
coding agent and aim it at a small local
model. It's built for the frontier's
flavor of tool calling and a giant
context window,
>> [music]
>> and it faceplants on a 7B. The
cautionary tale everyone links is the
developer who tried exactly that on a 32
gig laptop and watched the model
confidently describe his code without
ever once opening a file. Lighter plain
text tools handle weak models far
better. And whatever you run, keep the
agent in a sandbox. [music]
One hallucinated delete command
shouldn't be able to take your real
drive down with it.
What local gives you is control. The
model can't be silently swapped, rate
limited at the worst moment, deprecated,
or switched off by a policy you never
saw. Your code never leaves the
building,
plenty of people finance, healthcare,
anything under an NDA is the only
version their legal team will ever
approve. It runs on a plane, in a
basement, through [music] an outage, and
once the hardware's paid off, running it
flat out all weekend costs [music] you
electricity. What you give up is just as
real. The hardest reasoning and the long
roam free agent jobs still belong to the
frontier. A giant context [music]
is slower to chew through on your
machine, and you signed up for a second
job, the person [music] who fixes all
this when a driver update breaks it at
11:00 p.m. The skeptics land two hits.
One, this isn't as democratic as it
sounds. The capability is free, but the
hardware is a wall, and just buy a 64
gig Mac is a punchline to anyone on a
budget. Two, the reverse trap, where a
weak model [music] flops a task and you
burn an hour wrestling it into something
you'd have done yourself in 10 minutes.
Mitchell Hashimoto, who built HashiCorp,
made that case. For the hardest work on
a $5,000 machine, local still isn't
there. For most everyday work, local
model isn't a worst frontier model, it's
a different tool with a different deal
attached. And the most economical move
today isn't full local, it's hybrid. Let
a frontier model plan the big messy
thing, let your local model grind out
the well-defined pieces for free,
escalate the hard 20% back to the cloud.
Own what you can, rent what you must.
Zoom out and the [music] gap isn't
closing so much as getting redrawn. At
the very top, the frontier still pulls
away. The best closed models notched
further ahead this year. The lag between
the frontier and what you can run at
home has shrunk from a couple of years
to roughly 6 months. Open weights
already make up a big chunk of real
usage. The push behind them is
structural. [music]
Unified memory machines and AI chips
opening a third hardware path. Plus the
efficiency tricks that keep [music]
stuffing more capability into less
memory. The pull the other way is just
as real. The labs can keep the very best
behind the paywall and raise a ceiling
you can't follow. Whether it's you comes
down to a few questions. Already have a
24 gig card or 32 gig plus Mac. Spend a
lot of your day on bounded coding work
and like the idea of nobody being able
to touch your setup. Build the local
daily driver. Keep a cheap cloud sub for
the heavy lifting. Mostly turn big
agents loose on giant [music] code bases
or the hardware budget isn't there or
you'd rather not baby sit your own
infrastructure, the subsidized cloud
plan is still the rational call. One
more thing we've covered before. The
reason that cloud plan feels like a
steal is that someone else is eating the
cost for now and that can end on their
terms, not yours. The model on the box
under your desk can't be rug [music]
pulled, can't be repriced, can't be
retired out from under you. It's slower,
[music] it's less clever, but it's
yours. For a growing number of
developers, that last word is the one
[music] that finally tips it.
>> Mhm.